من جهتي هكذا ينقص الصوت برجع الامين
العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي ان جميع الحلفاء
متفقون على انضمام اوكرانيا للحلف واضاف
السلطه الملك في تصريحات له خلال اجتماعي
وزراء خارجيه الحلف في العاصمه النرويجيه
اوسلو ان روسيا ليس لديها حق الاعتراض على
توسعه الحلف
جدول اعمالنا مزدحم قبل قمه فيلينيوس ومن
الملفات التي سنبحثها تعزيز دعم الحلف
لاوكرانيا وتطلعاتها للانضمام اليه لقد
قدم الدول الحلف دعما غير مسبوق لكياف
وكلها متفقه على ان ابواب النيتو مفتوحه
لانضمام دول جديده وجميع اعضائه متفقون
على ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوان في الحلف
وهذا قرار تتخذه الدول الاعضاء وليست
موسكو من يرفض او يقبل توسع النيتو لكن
الاولويه الان هي للحفاظ على اوكرانيا
دوله ذات سياده